[Music]
time now for pft on yahoo sports he's
peter king i'm mike florio and we're
here with all the top stories in the nfl
super bowl dominating all week long and
will be the dominant headline on monday
when we know who's won and who's lost so
peter what will be
monday morning's super bowl headline in
your opinion
um my i think the super bowl headline on
monday morning is going to be
tampa bay's defense finally is a match
for patrick mahomes
um when they played mike i watched this
game the other day back on nfl game pass
and it was like
uh the tampa bay defensive secondary had
not even studied
tyreek hill and mahomes they were no
match for tyreek hill greatest game of
his career 13 catches 269 yards three
touchdowns
at one point i wrote about this in my
column this week at one point on
television tony romo says you know don't
look now but tyree kill is on pace for a
thousand yard game
and he had 133 yards in the first eight
minutes of the game
but but i think i'm putting my trust and
faith right now in todd bowles
and the maturity of a secondary that's
growing up before our very eyes mike
what happened in their three biggest
plays of tampa bay season so far aaron
rodgers goes incomplete incomplete
incomplete
and that's secondary the top six guys in
that secondary mic
are all 24 years and younger so they're
growing up before our eyes and in my
opinion
they're going to have to be the ones to
win this game
so easy to overlook the buccaneers
defense because of the tom brady factor
but it's the defense that stepped up
against the saints at a time when the
saints were moving toward a 10 or a 14
point lead in the third quarter and
really turned the momentum of the game
around in one fell swoop and it was the
defense as you said that's different
three straight possessions with tom
brady interceptions the first one
resulted in a green bay touchdown the
next two three and out with sacks you've
got both tackles out for the chiefs
you've got jpp and shaq barrett on the
front end you have devon white and
levante david at the next level and then
you've got that secondary
yeah look i
i could see a way that the dominoes fall
that gives us an old school 70s 80s
style blowout with the chiefs running
away with it
but but tom brady has always kept it
close in the super bowl and if you keep
it close and you have this guy who is
chasing number seven
even with what we saw from the chiefs
last year against the 49ers if you give
the buccaneers and brady that opening
that opportunity they're not going to
blow it i don't think uh it's i guess
go ahead every game that brady has
played in the super bowl these nine
games all of them have been single score
games with the one exception 13-3 over
the rams that game was three to three
midway through the fourth quarter so i
agree with you mike brady's gonna keep
this one close
he keeps it close and uh finds a way to
win i think although who knows i we both
picked the buccaneers to win the super
bowl before the season for me that is
the ultimate blind squirrel eating an
acorn i don't think i've even gotten
close but i just knew that once brady
got ensconced and comfortable we would
see this
emergence and and we've seen it and
we'll see if they can carry it all the
way to the top of the mountain now that
they are one step away from winning it
all he's peter king i'm mike florio
enjoy the super bowl and we'll see you
here next time
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports